when you find something you're good at
yeah go for it's not about being
wonderful no no I have that title safety
about making a business decision right
hi I'm Mark Cuban I'm a bully look at me
what's that of that much steam kuben
going forward since Paul's a three man
polish
hello believe nation I'm Evan Carmichael
my one word is believe and I believe
that entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the major problems of the world
so to help you on your journey today
we're going to learn from billionaire
shark tech investor Mark Cuban and my
take on his top ten rules of success
volume two and as always guys if you're
watching if you hear something that
really resonates with you please leave
it down the comments below put quotes
around it so other people can be
inspired and when you write it down it's
much more likely to stick for yourself
as well enjoy
sometimes being young and trying things
are so naive and you don't know any
better
all you do is learn and if you fail it
doesn't matter and so whether I was 9 10
12 1621 the failures were irrelevant and
you know whether you're you know nine
twelve sixteen twenty one twenty two
twenty four you know I'm sleeping on the
couch you know I have a car with a hole
in the floorboard you know I'm living
like a bum and like a student and so
what did I have to lose and so I think
that influenced me as much as anything
so it you know my dad was like go for it
you know don't why not what have you got
to lose you know you have to sleep on a
different couch so I think that that was
motivation the type of person you are
that you know kind of points to the
things you're good at are you 12 you're
not going to know or you get 16 you're
not going to know if you're 18 maybe if
you have a special talent yeah
right you know you can throw a baseball
100 miles an hour you can sing and your
voice is incredible you know you're you
know a concert pianist you're a chess
grandmaster if you have a specific skill
set or talent that just immediately
propels you to top yeah you want to
follow that yeah but I remember having a
list I still have it when I graduated
from college I was getting ready to
graduate and all the different
industries that I thought I might want
to partake in when you find something
you're good at
yeah go for it I was never really into
technology when I was a kid but then as
I got a job that used it I found out I
was good at it and once I found out I
was good at it then it became a lot more
fun yeah you know when you're good at
something it's almost always fun yeah
and once it was fun and I combined that
with you know my business skills then I
thought okay I know how to make money at
this stuff because I know how to sell
now I know tech that gives me something
I love to do and so you know what I oh I
tell people the key is find something
you love to do and be great at it yeah
because once you do that it's all gravy
what if I offered you 1.25 million
dollars to sell the whole company's mark
you're saying screw the other sharks yep
I like what you guys are doing I want
you to come back to me with a percentage
I don't want you to even talk to these
guys you're asking to take that option
with you right now
Nora you're not a very nice guy thought
about B being wonderful no I have that
title same thing about making a business
decision right hi I'm Mark Cuban I'm a
bully look at me what's that about what
like I said guys you got to pay to play
attention in this room I can feel it
it's offensive you got a shot here right
don't let these guys drag you down are
you really interested in it I like the
idea you really think cooking bacon
bedside is a good idea
I loved your passion I love your
knowledge I'm waiting for the bite yeah
there's a but coming
you've got a 24-second shot clock
$750,000 I've never seen grade like that
that's unbelievable great you broke up
with your potential partner without even
looking at them you're a savage just a
lean mean sharp machine baby if I say
yes to whatever you're Connor is you
have to tell me that you will say yes
immediately and we have a deal
one hundred thousand dollars - wait a
minute for 20% equity done done and done
do you like that Barbara I don't like it
one did dance why that's a compliment to
you Martha I screwed you but it's a
compliment in you matter this isn't the
Rose Garden it's the shark tank and you
know what sometimes you got to take the
fight and sometimes you're the chump you
just have to try different things and
even even if 99% of them fail you only
have to be right one time you don't have
to figure it all out in advance you can
be wrong you could pick the wrong career
you can pick the wrong job you can pick
the wrong house you can pick the wrong
whatever but you get it right one time
you're set but if you don't try and if
you don't go out there and try all those
different things you'll never get that
one time and so it's not a question of
okay how much stuff is different stuff
do I do or how many different things
should you try try them all try them all
until you find the one you like and then
it's like it gets really easy because
even what's up you're on a mission
you're loving what you do you know and
then then it gets easy and so that's
just the approach I've always tried to
instill in people who work for me and
myself I knew I was wired to be excited
about business how or why I don't know
but you know and there's certain guys
they have the genetics to jump out of
the gym right remember certain guys you
know that
you know when they golf they have the
muscle memory and the discipline you
know Dirk Nowitzki may not be the most
talented guy in the NBA but his
discipline and his focus to do what's
necessary to be successful he's willing
to do and combine it with being seven
feet tall and being skilled you know it
makes him an amazing basketball player
so it's understanding what your skill
set is finding the right place to use
those skills and then going for it you
know will that make you 250 grand it
depends if you pick the right industry
but whatever industry you pick if you
outwork everybody if you try to be a
little smarter than everybody if you try
to be a better salesperson and everybody
if you try to be better prepared than
everybody you've got your best chance
because if you don't do it and somebody
else does you I have the same work like
someone's trying to take it all away
from you you know working I actually
work like no one's spending 24 hours
working 24 hours to take it all away
from you in and that's kind of the way I
look at it I remember asking my dad - I
want a new basketball shoes because I
was a basketball junkie back then he's
like well your shoes work if you want a
new pair of tennis shoes you have to go
out there and get a job and I'm like dad
I'm 12 years old and just so happens he
was playing poker with his buddies and
one of his buddies was like well I got a
job for you I've got these garbage bags
that we distribute you could sell the
door-to-door I'm like okay and it was
when I was selling them and realized he
that I'd like to sell and that I could
sell and that I recognized that selling
was was about providing the service and
creating value for people that I knew
that I would literally back then I knew
that I could always succeed I mean I
remember I was 16 I think when I started
a stamp company and started going to
stamp shows and trade shows and just
working a little bit harder than other
people and and trading up from one stamp
to the next I remember one time I
started with a quarter and bought a
stamp and left with $50 thinking hey if
I could do this I could do anything and
and it's not that everything worked I
failed a lot but I never ever felt like
I wouldn't be able to work hard enough
to succeed also always say it's not
about passion
everybody's got passion for something
Yeah right don't follow your passions
follow your efforts because people say
look you know I was passionate to play
baseball okay Ashley play basketball
doesn't mean out all the sudden I was
going to be good enough yeah but I found
myself spending being really curious
about business being really curious
about technology and that curiosity is
really what drove me and I think surely
if you're young today curiosity is great
always learning and trying to find new
things and being curious about new
things because that's what leads you to
that path trying to figure out in
advance yeah that's hard because you
don't know what you don't know be
prepared
understand put yourselves in the shoes
of the people or the businesses that
you're working with the message that I
just got on cyberdust is a perfect
example if he were to put himself in my
shoes it would be obvious that cyberdust
is important to me I'm trying to push
everybody to message using it I've
volunteered and Dave mentioned that hey
I'm going to be answering questions long
after this is over for you people from
everybody sending me messages so
cyberdust is obviously important to me
and so if you're able to do something
that reflects something that's important
to me or whoever it is that you're
working or trying to get a job where
they're trying to get an internship with
or trying to get an investment from if
you can put yourself in their shoes and
put yourself in context of what's
important to them your chances of being
successful increased 99 percent a good
thousand four right and one other point
I'll leave with you right if you're
working for somebody the best way to be
successful is by reducing the stress of
those around you it's not about you I
mean it's always about me but that's a
different thing but it's not about you
it's about the people around you if
you're reducing the stress of the people
around you those are the people those
people start to gravitate towards you
they want to work with you because you
may go into work easier more pleasant
you help them accomplish their goals you
help put them in a position to succeed
by reducing their stress you know Shark
Tank I do the show not because of their
great investments but I do the show
because it sends the message to to kids
8 to 80 that the American Dream is alive
and well um you know you can watch the
show and and come to realize that some
money out of Iowa or you know in middle
of nowhere in Texas can start a company
and you know turn it into something
special and I think you know so many
families watch the show together that is
just you know in particularly in this
day and age when so many people are
saying what's wrong with this and what's
wrong with that what's wrong with
America
it just really reinforces that you know
somebody with an idea who's willing to
you know go beyond just an idea to a
company phase and really work something
special can happen and and you know just
reinforcing that is really important to
me what makes it work is like
everybody's got ideas like most people
just think I'll it's my idea and I don't
have this right the people that get it
done they don't look at the obstacles
they look at the opportunities you know
instead of coming up there which had a
connection which I have money which I
had this like to do with the surfboard
man you went out got upon the youth
surfboard and he started putting it all
together and it was just his time you
know and then he took it built one
figured it out build another one and
then it's the same thing with some of
the other one pretty much all the other
companies where you know rather than
finding the excuses why they can't do it
they find the reasons to make it work
and then they just butt to bust their
ass and good things happen Steve Chubin
going forward your sense follows a 3-man
polling and there's still more fighting
to happen hotshots
back out I still drop the big good fight
for team kuben an ace actually yup and
that maybe do you think they can close
it out right now I mean they've got a
lot of depth timers mm turret Eve's on
the Nexus originals on the Nexus to know
Beggan your last hit without a base our
hands here title we're all there waiting
it's so much tax hike become an indoor
cover one more flight it's an impressive
support from these guides for cyber
smile as well I was fun to raise some
money for charity
Cuba clearly delighted with his victory
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed if you want to get your
pick of who I should profile next in the
top ten check out the link in the
description and go and cast your vote I
also want to give a quick Charlotte -
Megan Lofton from the bootstrap boutique
channel Megan thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word and doing the review on your
YouTube channel as well as posting to
your Twitter account I really appreciate
the support and I'm glad you enjoyed the
read so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
[Music]
you know I didn't have as many personal
relationships as I probably would have
liked you know I put personal
relationships aside you know I had
girlfriends where it was like me or your
business and out you know what was your
name again you know
you think I'm kidding so it probably
took me to an extreme but yeah I gave up
on personal relationships in a big
respect because I really was on a
mission and once I once I realized I was
good so when I sold my first company I
bought a lifetime pass in American
Airlines and my goal was just a party
with like a rock star in as many
countries with as many people as I
possibly could then I went back and got
involved in the streaming business and I
remember sitting there and telling you
know we had probably 10 employees they
looked the streaming thing I think is
going to be really big and so we really
have to focus and there's going to be
some sacrifices and if you're willing to
make those sacrifices let's go and if
you're not I understand you know you
make your own decisions and I was
willing to make those sacrifices and um
you know it all turned out great in the
long run but during that time wasn't
always wasn't always easy and wasn't
always um it was tough sometimes I
always get everything back at half words
you know I like to challenge myself and
um I went to Mount Lebanon High School
in Pittsburgh and I wanted to take
business classes my junior year only
they didn't offer any business classes
and so I decided I'd take some college
business classes but University of
Pittsburgh didn't offer any real
business classes either so I said you
know I'm going to challenge myself and
so I took a couple night classes at the
University of Pittsburgh my junior year
in high school did well in them and
didn't wasn't really challenged all that
much at all and so I just dropped out of
high school and instead of going back
for my senior year I went that went to
the University of Pittsburgh and started
taking classes there um and now like my
buddies are like where'd you go and it's
just I just I've always tried to
challenge myself you've got to know your
own skillset right and you've got to
know how that fits within your company's
lifecycle um you know some companies are
slow slow grind and you just have to
understand that and you've just got to
bide your time and still until it starts
to click and then grow with it quickly
you know if you're trying to release a
product that needs to be ubiquitous
you've got to go as fast as you can and
and
and you know release the product ya know
long yeah and and you know there's a lot
of people say you know perfection is the
enemy of profitability right and that
doesn't mean you have to wait to us a
perfect product
you know Sabri owes to the perfect
sample we still haven't it's been almost
two years we still haven't advertised it
yet because we know it's not ready yet
you know and so it's been a slow growth
grind because that's we wanted we want
feedback you know we want to keep on
learning we're evolving um but it really
just depends on what the product is that
you know a barbershop right is in an app
is it a service is it a product but you
know the key is looking for the
low-hanging fruit what are the at what
are what customers are willing to write
you a check or commit to it you know so
that they're willing to integrate it
into their daily lives or integrated
into their daily business and so getting
a commitment either through time or
revenue is typically what I look for and
so if I can get a commitment then I'm
going to be able to learn I'm going to
see how they use it to they sustained
usage and then once I get the next one
you know hopefully it came a little bit
faster than the first one then I can ask
for referrals and then the next one then
the next one and I just try to ramp it
up you know when I bought the mouse we
had no season ticket-holder base and so
literally it was a matter of just
putting a list of former season ticket
holders and a white pages back then you
know on my desk next to my phone and
making phone calls see you yeah me yeah
because if I'm not going to do an OP I
sign something else right so just get on
the phone hey this mark here on the new
owner of the Dallas Mavericks you know I
like them but I've already it's not
though this is my baby this we can't get
regular silicates or something make
those calls wants to get to a quarter
you're a million you're making the work
but that's open you know and that's fine
and good right because everybody's got
their own goals right and but still I
don't want anybody at the mass to be
able to say well he's not willing to do
the work right there's you know if I
walk around I'm picking up all the
papers I'm not saying go get that picked
up I'm like okay that's trash I'm
picking it up um so but in terms of
speed of growth it's really you got to
get that first customer first and then
when you get that first what did you
learn reiterate get
next customer and then hopefully as you
learn more and more through the process
than the next one the next one the next
one becomes come by and faster